me gustaría que recordéis la última vez
que acudisteis al médico por un problema
de salud pensad qué preguntas os hizo si
os exploro si os miro a los ojos si os
sentís teis escuchados seguramente cada
uno de nosotros haya tenido una
experiencia diferente unos buenos otras
malas y bueno lo cierto es que nuestro
sistema sanitario es muy bueno pero cada
vez está más saturado los médicos tienen
que ver a muchos pacientes cada día
y lo cierto es que ya no pueden dedicar
a cada uno el tiempo que requiere además
gran parte de su trabajo se ha
convertido en recoger datos en ordenador
y también se están volviendo esclavos de
un sistema que lo que hace es priorizar
que aumente la eficiencia y que se
reduzcan los costes además es un sistema
que ya no ve al paciente como un ser
humano sino que lo reduce a informes a
datos la medicina se está deshumanizando
antes la relación entre médicos y
pacientes era muy preciada había
confianza había presencia tiempo se
estableció una conexión humana
los pacientes sentían que los médicos se
preocupaban de verdad e intentaban
ayudarles en todo lo que pudieran y los
médicos veían que su trabajo trascendía
que realmente marcaba la diferencia
esto está desapareciendo porque no hay
tiempo habrá quien considere que esto no
es tan relevante porque al final con
todos los tratamientos y las pruebas
actuales los pacientes acabarán
recuperándose igual aunque hayan sido
tratados con cierta frialdad pero a mí
me parece que esto es un error porque
está demostrado que una buena
comunicación médico-paciente está
asociada con un mejor pronóstico con las
prisas como hay más probabilidades de
que cometamos un error de diagnóstico y
este es un problema importante porque al
final acabaremos malgastando recursos
sanitarios y los pacientes no acabarán
recibiendo aquellos cuidados que
necesitan
y si os dijera que la inteligencia
artificial la ya nos puede ayudar a
román y zar la medicina
resulta un poco paradójico porque bueno
cuando vimos ya nos imaginamos una
consciencia artificial a los robots
conquistando el mundo y esto no suena
muy humanístico verdad pero es que es
ciencia ficción
cuando hablamos de ella en realidad nos
referimos a machine learning aprendizaje
automático a algoritmos o modelos
estadísticos que han sido entrenados
para desempeñar una tarea muy específica
como podría ser corregir la gramática de
nuestros mensajes o filtrar el spam de
nuestro correo electrónico desbloquear
el teléfono con nuestro rostro os
recomendamos películas en base a
nuestros gustos todas estas herramientas
están basadas en ya y forman parte de
nuestro día a día
es cuestión de tiempo que la haya
también pase a formar una parte
fundamental de la medicina de hecho ya
existen numerosas investigaciones que
demuestran su utilidad uno de los
ejemplos más interesantes es la
retinopatía diabética que es una de las
principales causas en el mundo de
ceguera
si realizamos un análisis periódico de
ojos a todos los pacientes con diabetes
podríamos evitar la pérdida de visión en
hasta un 90% de los casos pero claro
cuántos oftalmólogos serían necesarios
para esta tarea y cuántos años tardarían
en analizar todas las imágenes si
recurriéramos a la guía podríamos
resolver este problema en cuestión de
minutos y no nos arruinaría moss en el
proceso los algoritmos de ella
replican el comportamiento humano y lo
hacen a una velocidad pasmosa pero no
aprenden por razonamiento sino que lo
hacen por imitación en base a ensayo y
error y en este caso concreto lo que
hicieron los investigadores puede
presentar al modelo miles de imágenes de
ojos y le indicaron cuáles pertenecían a
pacientes con retinopatía diabética y
cuáles a personas sanas después para
evaluar el rendimiento del modelo le
presentaron más imágenes pero esta vez
no le indicaron a quién pertenecían y le
hicieron adivinar
la exactitud que lograron fue del 95 por
ciento
así pues la eia presenta unas grandes
oportunidades en diagnóstico puede
reducir significativamente el tiempo y
los costes y permite identificar
precozmente distintas patologías además
también puede evitar errores médicos
otra faceta que presenta la guía es que
permite reconocer patrones complejos que
se escapan a la mirada humana así por
ejemplo se ha desarrollado un algoritmo
que analiza las ondas cerebrales y puede
predecir en pacientes graves si van a
tener un ataque epiléptico horas antes
de que ocurra esto permite avisar a los
médicos para que tomen las medidas
necesarias actúan rápido puede salvar la
vida de los pacientes
teniendo en cuenta todas estas
oportunidades que habría pensar
valeria a reemplazar a los médicos en el
futuro
es decir esto es casi como afirmar que
los matemáticos no son necesarios porque
tenemos calculadoras
y bueno pues es que la isla ya presenta
muchísimas ventajas pero también
conlleva una serie de riesgos imaginemos
que entrenamos un modelo para
diagnosticar cáncer de piel y le
mostramos miles de imágenes de los
celulares malignos y benignos aunque
este modelo sea capaz de distinguir el
99% de los casos con exactitud si el
paciente tiene cáncer o no este modelo
no podrá razonar
no sabrá ni qué es el cáncer ni qué es
un paciente ni que el cáncer está en la
piel porque aprenden por imitación en
base a los datos que le presentamos y no
nos equivoquemos los datos no son
neutros pueden poseer sesgos
si solamente le hemos presentado al
modelo imágenes de personas de raza
blanca luego es posible que tenga
problemas a la hora de diagnosticar
pacientes de otras razas y esto es un
problema grave porque sin darnos cuenta
habremos diseñado una vía racista con lo
cual la principal lección es que debemos
identificar y evitar los sesgos en
nuestros modelos y para esto es
fundamental comprender de dónde de dónde
provienen los datos y explorarlos a
fondo
en este ejemplo lo ideal sería re
entrenar el modelo presentando las
imágenes con pacientes de distintas
razas y así
evitaríamos crear desigualdades la otra
gran lección es que tenemos que
garantizar que los modelos sean seguros
qué ocurriría si le decimos a un
paciente que está sano en base a los
resultados de nuestro modelo y resulta
que este paciente tiene un melanoma
por lo tanto es fundamental que los
modelos sean validados adecuadamente
además
es muy muy importante establecer de
quién es la responsabilidad si se
produce un error médico y si ese
paciente que hemos diagnosticado mal se
muere de quién es la culpa del médico de
quien diseñó el algoritmo de la propia
vida
teniendo en cuenta estas limitaciones no
creo que la ella pueda sustituir nunca a
los médicos y de hecho aunque
consiguiéramos modelos que sean
plenamente seguros e imparciales estos
van a seguir sin tener entendimiento son
como loros que aprenden a hablar no
interaccionan con el paciente solamente
extraen conclusiones en base a los datos
que reciben
y para diagnosticar a un paciente hay
que entenderlo de forma global como una
persona que proviene de un entorno
determinado y no todo puede reducirse a
datos
de este modo la ya sería una herramienta
complementaria pero no sustitutiva de
los médicos por un lado actuarían como
asistentes encargándose de tareas
repetitivas que puedan hacer que cuando
bien que los médicos pero más rápido y
por otro lado serían una especie de
asesores que ayudarían al médico a
encajar las piezas del puzzle pero
después el médico sería el encargado de
poner contexto y tomarlas las decisiones
necesarias
al final la guía lo que harías es
proporcionar al médico del tiempo y los
recursos que necesita para poder
centrarse en lo más importante que es la
atención y el tratamiento de los
pacientes con la implantación de la guía
en la práctica clínica tenemos una
oportunidad de oro para recuperar la
relación entre médicos y pacientes y
para ello es muy importante que se
produzca un cambio social del
entendimiento de la medicina
debemos volver a colocar a los pacientes
en el punto de mira y promover la
prevención además de aprovechar todas
las oportunidades que brinda la haya
además también es fundamental introducir
nuevas regulaciones y sistemas que
garanticen la calidad de los datos para
que los modelos sean seguros e
imparciales
nos encontramos a las puertas de una
gran revolución médica y creo que es un
momento muy emocionante porque tenemos
la ocasión y también la responsabilidad
de conseguir una medicina más humana y
de mayor calidad muchas gracias
[Aplausos]